well some sad news for those who follow  las vegas braden smith's  recent successful run on jeopardy  brayden passed away earlier this month  from complications following a recent  surgery his parents thank  everyone for their thoughts they've  started a memorial fund for his name  dedicated  to helping local students further their  education we have a link to that fund on  our website 8newsnow.com  we also reached out to jeopardy the  show's team released a statement that  reads quote  the jeopardy family is heartbroken by  the tragic loss of braden smith  he was kind funny and absolutely  brilliant  our deepest condolences go out to  braden's family he will be missed  we here at channel 8 send our  condolences as well brayden was just  24 years old